this is the diary the now I want to know
if that Sun TV was voiced by Tina from
Bob's Burgers the whole time
because I only started watching Bob's
Burgers like last year and this poor guy
always somehow gets even though he's
thankfully playing a boy in this he's
also kind of playing a girl at some
point like he imagines himself as the
girl and stuff or maybe it's good for
him maybe it's freeing I don't know
girls playing boys yeah it happens all
the time
oh no I know it he's hilarious and Bob's
Burgers um and that's like all I could
see throughout this episode but because
it's like the exact same boy it's just
this depressed like fourteen-year-old
just always talks like this especially
when she goes know like everything's
that monitor so but anyway so he finally
goes outside because he doesn't go
outside that much and comes across this
diary of this girl they doesn't know
gets really sucked in and some pages are
missing he wants to know how it ends so
he goes kind of looking for answers Jake
gets involved as well and eventually
through all these strange turns of
events including someone who created
this box with two dancing kitties and
somehow could predict from the box that
she did things in caves says where she
is and they go find the cave find out
how the story ends she becomes a nurse
and his nurse poundcake and then they're
wondering whether or not they should
find the boyfriend Justin he's like nah
and even the ripped out pages weren't
really anything they were just like
angry rantings about Justin so yeah
there's a couple interesting things
going on in this I think with you know
he's getting so sucked into the story
you know to a point where it's like he's
not seeing what's happening to her he's
interpreting it as him he's seeing
himself as her and I guess the first
thing I really thought of even though
I'm sure it's kind of I was having
before with a lot of like online stuff
where you can sort of be too
character doesn't create these worlds
and stuff this is some adventure times
talked about a couple times you know
where you can sort of be this different
identity be this different person be a
different gender different species you
can be a different anything and get
really really sucked in I don't want to
be done
I want to be geez oh no it dont I'd have
to drink Blue Mountain - the whole time
oh that's true I can't drink dude screw
that you don't drink the do you do the
dude if there's anyone I believe
actually does for do it would be I need
some alone time
and yeah I get the feeling cuz that's
always kind of thing to talk about more
and more is how a sucked in can you get
into your fantasies cuz you know
fantasies are very healthy very helpful
the you know great writers do it and
people just working through things do it
pretend like they're different people to
get through stuff but other people just
reject their reality to be someone else
and especially with the Internet and you
know just becoming these different
identities and with this whole weirdness
at now of like you know of transgenders
and people that believe they were born a
different gender or different identity
and stuff I mean so much of this there's
such an awareness to it where I think
it's a right now it's a very fun gray
ground you know a good gray line where
it's like you know where is okay like
this is totally fine acceptable at what
point is it like you're not you know
wolf emic Fox Fox or you need to God so
I have to be somebody else or be
yourself I should say um so yeah I kind
of I like that they dealt more which if
it's a diary it's not something online
it's not technology it's just something
as simple as the writings of someone
that did exist so it's not even like
pertain be someone that doesn't exist
which I think made even more interesting
and at some of it they surprisingly got
right like the crab yeah that killed me
I even found a cure for my crab
um so uh I like that I like that he
wanted to find what happened to her and
it was kind of perfectly anti-climactic
like it sounds like it's gonna build us
something big that's like I just ran
away for cave a little bit got over it
what became a nurse you know lives uh
yeah the life of a nurse you know seems
to be doing well and then we came to
finding Justin it's practice the same
thing like just either hey I'm just so
tired of looking for the other person
I'm done or be just like well Darwin was
so anti-climactic they'll probably
anti-cop exit like say even just the
three pages be torn up wait those three
pages oh yeah that was just getting mad
about Justin yeah I love how
anti-climatic that was um I thought that
was both really funny and just so true
to life so do you think these grant
answers and sometimes it's just general
Isaac's usually the stuff you
thing's gonna be general that has
like the weird beacon free frickin big
entire answers thank you thank you thank
you frankerz rabbit uh so no I I thought
was a lot of fun uh for you fat so no
what the hell you were just saying
before that Howard Joe Sam - Sam never
see this is the perfect example if
someone is keeping ya up someone I know
so many samne you time just gonna sleep
um no the episode was fine I mean he
actually you pretty much cleared this
one up I don't think there's anything
more to it now you always gotta say
something deeper you always do pretties
over here it's like a flavor oh why did
I do that
yeah um no I think it's a you hit the
nail mad with the whole people trying to
escape into something that they're not
and TV uses it as an escape oh I want to
say this really quickly in the beginning
when TV is playing a video game
and it comes up and it you know happens
Doug said specifically oh that's dragon
dragon warrior not Zelda and I want to
say I'm so happy because I'm tired of
the internet only knowing like five
Nintendo games the only Nintendo
awareness they only know Mario Zelda
Metroid what are the ones in my donkey
kong yeah and like poem on but I mean
like I'm so glad that Doug's like oh
that's like Dragon Warrior yes at first
I thought was Elva to but then with the
little square came up I'm just like oh
that's dragon boy for the record I know
cuz there's an RPG that was actually the
first RPG I was introduced um like this
is just stab it who would you
like to stab it yes
breed fire on you Jesus just show
it to me alright a fight now what you're
like I don't want to type I don't want
to say yes I want to stand the fight so
actually the only thing did bother me
about that game when you walked up the
stairs you had to like go to the menu
and actually select to go downstairs I'm
like would you like to do the next stair
yes what's your job there yeah I did
love the game okay I believe I know it's
for RPGs it's fine I guess I just um but
no like it's almost like anyone getting
into a book getting so drawn up into
that book that it becomes like almost
part of themselves but like the
there was someone who actually wrote
this I think it makes it a little bit
more fun um I I also do that still love
the whole yeah like I had a Cray it's a
crab handed and this happened and then
this happened in the seven that it
actually did happen yeah well at least
the crab hand happened the way we got
that part at least Lester that the
wrestles a little vague we don't know if
it did but you know with the UM because
like you said people get sucked into
books there's been tons of you know the
stories or whatever people game sucked
into you know fiction before the
internet before these but I think there
is something to it's much easier to
happen at it's much more available and
accessible and even bigger to make these
realities seem like realities so I think
that's why there's even more attention
now and they're drawing even more focus
on it it's because even though this
stuff did happen before I think it was
with probably a smaller group and now
because it's much more accessible and
anyone can just go live in a fantasy
world now I mean these worlds are just
fully developed and there's tons of
people that will support you
yeah yeah that's what you are great I'm
and then you make up your character you
know and that's something where it's
like I be doing I have a problem if you
do I think it like ice I think it's very
healthy you can work through a lot of
stuff that way but I think they're all
terrible human area there's definitely
that thin line though where you know how
far do you go to where it gets unhealthy
it starts damage yeah your real life um
you know and I think that that's er what
it's talking about because it it did get
him outside it got him doing stuff but
he was also kind of rejecting his
reality to a publican you wouldn't even
tell what reality was also like rolling
around in the dirt going yeah yeah so I
like that like account blurred the line
and he does kind of come back and now
it's I'm curious if he actually will
continue to go outside or now if they'll
just stay in this room probably but like
once in a while he'll like maybe go
outside to look for another diary or
something it's almost like that I think
it's the whole anticlimactic
oh I'm on an adventure oh that's the end
I'm done maybe he'll go find like
another adventure some point probably
you know baby steps for him but yeah so
no I liked it I like ones that deal with
servi both identity and reality and how
tightly knit they are and like I said
what's you know fun and helpful and
what's damaging and you know clearly
denial so I kind of saw maybe possibly
tiny thing
connection to fanfic oh you get to that
point where like he needed more like
what he had wasn't enough he needed more
he wanted to figure out what it was so
he kind of created his own story and get
it kept going with it and everything and
instead of it being this picture of
someone else it was a picture of him and
address yeah you know it says me me I
mean Jake's like wait you say me I and I
like that I really like that blurring
the line and I'm like a fanfic where
someone's like oh I like this but I'm
gonna add more to it I think if they
didn't do then they just kept did they
wanted to find out about this girl and
what happened to her and he kept saying
her and what happened done yeah yeah
when he starts saying me that makes it
more interest that makes it more
relevant now in my opinion I it makes it
more intriguing yeah so no I thought was
good episode definitely really really
good so um yeah that's the last time
you'll see us both wearing red again
unless we you know color code next time
to or just until next week until next
week yes no wait no no we got our dates
mixed up until next year next year is
one you'll see all of these and you'll
just have to wait and see if we actually
do better are we that cool don't just
have to wait and see so um that's about
it and then we just like skip the next
seven and do seven others and then a
year from now post those seven and just
act like her
never even shown just act like skip
these huge episodes that everyone else
like well you know what we thought of
that so
anyway but or Troy let's start doing a
different show but do it as if it's
adventure look we'll do Everybody Loves
Raymond well we can't do that with Milo
no like actually review it though like
look there's Jake he looks really weird
okay no why is he kissing Finn that's
you or we could just end them in the
middle without any kind of in